ormai l'avrete capito che questo show è
soltanto una scusa per conoscere i vip
non c'è a livello artistico qua non c'è
niente c'è abbiamo cambiato anche il
colore della sedia è un chissenefrega io
questi video li sto facendo soltanto per
contattare i vip ei ciao è una scusa e
non so voi venire
certo è invece è solo per conoscerle
farmi la foto l'ospite di oggi
probabilmente lo conoscerete perché ha
vinto l'edizione del 2011 di xfactor ha
vinto 3 wind music awards e conosce una
persona che a quanto pare sa di bar
indiano
signore e signori francesca un nickname
[Musica]
come negli studi televisivi quel momento
di cartelloni con scritto e il 25
dicembre quando girano a maggio si stima
di tutto anche di dire buon natale
il tuo buon natale da parte di realtà
tipo era ottobre difficilissimo tra
l'altro sei veramente 6 tesa sono tese a
sei molto professionale e ne sono
abituata alla vita sociale cioè da un po
di tempo che va beh adesso sono in tour
il tour appena cominciato quindi in
realtà esco punto i venerdì sabato sera
per suonare il mio vg sezionato però
dopo insolito sto in conservatorio sto
chiusa a studiare oppure so in studio a
un periodo un po così
santo cielo l'infermiera avere persone
che vedono il tempio madre mi sento un
lato però sono un po preoccupato ma
guarda che la vita dell'artista c'è il
bello di fare questo lavoro è che è come
un po gli anni scolastici nel senso che
sordo che non è un anno scolastico che
inizia sempre a settembre
certo vorrei parlarti di questo allora
ho fatto una fatica incredibile per
cercare degli argomenti anche solo con
te perché mi sono guardato come ho fatto
con tutti gli ospiti interviste e video
anche piccoli talk show che hai fatto
non c'è una volta che tu non abbia
parlato solo di lavoro qua a me a me
quello non interessa mi interessa tutto
il resto della vita
perché io ho letto un'intervista dove tu
hai detto mi sono trasferita a milano
non ho neanche la televisione in casa
hai detto quasi si è stato un anno
bizzarro bellissimo però che tra l'altro
è finito da poco perché ho fatto da
agosto a ottobre praticamente di
quest'anno
non avevo la tv in casa cioè ce l'avevo
ma non sapevo di averla certo e questo
spiega la tv perché era nascosta in un
punto non ho capito e io in questa casa
c'è una cosa piccolissima di 30 c no 30
metri quadri di strumenti ogni tanto li
appoggiavi in bagno e un giorno mi rendo
conto che c'era tv vabbè ma non la userò
perché tanto non ho il tempo fisico di
guardarla il tiro poi un giorno mi rendo
conto a ma aspetta questa sera c'è c'era
mi sembra una coppa italia c'era
qualcosa del tipo milan juve non mi
ricordo ho detto no ma vera oggi da
accenderò guardata quindi quelli mi la
juve è stato il tumulo programma
televisivo in casa mia se i ragazzi di
dio mio tu e anche detto in
un'intervista dopo l'ultimo tour che
credo fosse quello prima di sopra la
tecno ipotizzo del 2017 probabilmente no
abbiamo finito questa estate si si hai
detto volevo mollare tutto e andare in
cui nonno si infatti è stato in turni
2016 e ho detto voglio mollare tutto
andare in colombia si comunque quando
finisce questo questa specie di anno
scolastico
sei veramente stanco ma non è una
stanchezza fisica oltre che quella
chiaramente è proprio che hai bisogno di
ricaricare l'energia anche vedere cose
nuove posti noi per dopo eventualmente
scrivere altre cose però fatto sta che
ho già presi biglietti per andare in
america latina da qua fra un quindici
giorni quindi abbiamo mantenuto la meno
male che sono stati due anni fruire
un altro principato con trento voglio
sapere cosa fai quando non fai niente ci
deve essere un momento o una giornata
all'anno durante quel periodo nel non
fai niente niente di vero
il nostro partendo un po stanche capire
però almeno 20 anni così anche bello
essere superati che questa età non mi
dire che il 23 anni prima
30 e non faccio niente la maggior parte
della mia settimana di una nave per
adesso guarda sarà veramente un grande
esercizio quello di provare a non fare e
su esercizi non era niente proprio
dedicherò metà del mio dicembre a questi
ve lo prometto
volevo parlare dell'ultimo singolo di
femme perché l'ho ascoltato e ho letto
alcune interpretazioni che ci sono su
internet ed erano molto interessanti e
volevo sapere da te i motivi per i quali
tu abbia scelto di fare un singolo del
genere di scriverlo così con tra l'altro
lo hai scritto a quattro mani con
calcutta
questo brano in realtà è un brano che
che parla un po del men's plaining in
generale che a questa cosa per cui ogni
tanto ci sono questi cliché per cui
sembra che le cose le sanno fare sugli
uomini oppure che ne so il classico uomo
che magari lo dice anche perché ormai è
nel suo retaggio culturale però dice a
non ti preoccupare faccio io faccio io
tu pensa lavare i piatti cioè queste
cose che chiaramente estrapolate da un
contesto analizzato è vicino ma non è
è normale questa cosa per cui vado in
giro con tutto questo disco e oltre
remixato e ho aggiunto anche questo
pezzo questo quello ligure para sopra
anche più sempre parati e sono molto
contento perché quello deve fare un
argomento per per essere affrontato deve
essere affrontato da tutti quanti donne
che io ho sempre sostenuto la la parità
di genere ma comunque in generale anche
l'uguaglianza nella diversità la
ricchezza la diversità sono temi che io
sostengo da anni c'è una cosa che mi
piace fare con con i vip che si chiama
gli scheletri nella count sono è una
rubrica mia mentale dove vado perché è
successo è successo ultimamente che per
denigrare una persona si andasse a
cercare anni indietro nel loro account
social qualche frase qualche battuta a
parte qua mi sono andato immediatamente
a cercare gli studi sociali
allora ho trovato una cosa ma la vediamo
dopo io non ho trovato niente 6 pulita
immacolata e poi vuoi andare in colombia
secondo me perché insieme a qualche
paletto
a un certo punto ariana grande è un pò
impazzita su internet perché c'è stato
del legge robot di scemi leggero del bo
discendo n
si è sfogata su twitter scrivendo una
cosa incredibile
tutti l'hanno criticate l'anno
bombardate lei ha poi ha rimosso questo
tweet per uno secondo me l'ha resa molto
più umana del previsto chiaramente a
volte a migrazione è successo ma conosco
che mie colleghe che veramente come se
dovessero per forza mossa il loro corpo
o dovessero per forza magari perdere
qualche chilo perché se ne perdi
qualcuno è meglio tutte queste cose sono
pesanti anche perché facciamo in musica
ma anche se facessi la modella anche
questa cosa è un tema molto molto fiero
perché chiaramente e qui si ruota tutto
il peso del del problema perché per una
cosa che per noi potrebbe se per noi
uomini potrebbe sembrare poco cioè la
fronte alta di haryana grave e al
fossato delle fotografie a quanto pare
l'anno bombardata di dio mio dio questa
fronte incredibile e lei ha scritto ho
visto che tutti quanti mi state
prendendo in giro per la mia fronte
scusatemi se una fronte grande almeno
solo carina e non prendo in giro le
fronti degli altri suck my big ariana
grande affinità un tweet dicendo suck my
big fatto bene a fattura secondo me
chiaramente ogni tanto ci servono anche
delle scosse un po per pero a vedere
tantissime persone si stanno mobilitando
per sensibilizzare su queste cose qua
perché chiaramente noi siamo adesso
un po come avere un'arma in mano quindi
bisogna sempre stare attenti a quello
che si scrive perché magari certi
commenti dal vivo una persona di faresti
mai no assolutamente no
49 per cento delle volte so che vorresti
parlare delle donne che ti hanno
ispirata un po per questo punto da
questo punto di vista per questi
argomenti
sicuramente anche per quello che sta
facendo tuttora emma watson e poi quando
ero piccola leggevo questi libri di
bianca pitzorno che è una scrittrice che
mi ha sempre molto ispirata e leggere i
suoi libri mi hanno un semplice e sempre
stato molto bello per me perché lei
parla sempre di ragazzine molto ribelli
che non vogliono essere dentro un canone
preciso e quindi sicuramente tidei
questi due figure è stato anche
difficile per me perché sapevo che
avresti voluto parlare di queste cose
qua quindi nelle armi un argomento del
genere strategie e stata dura e stata
dura e fate chiudiamo in bellezza
no non si fa niente fa strano però è la
cosa più umana a parte a livello
lavorativo che ho trovato it e su
internet
sto provando a dormire con varie
magliette dei vari giocatori di calcio
per provare dell'esperienza e quelli
effettivamente sto facendo dei dei sogni
più rilassanti del soldi quindi fissi
mentre chiaramente alberto angela è un
grande peso con tutti ed è caduto cioè
in uno stronzo
mi sono sempre tipo dinosauri o cose
tipo di essere nell'antica grecia
chiaramente diventa pesante parliamo di
altro ho sognato che giocavo con
cristiano ronaldo fifa ho insegnato
anche di essere delle tue tekken
oppure c'è questo car c'è questo del
gioco
scusami tu mi stai nominando di
videogiochi che non dove trovi il tempo
di giocare professore io sono super
appassionata di tutti quei giochi che si
giocavano con la playstation 1 e mi
ricorderò sempre che tantissimi
tantissimi anni fa ho detto mia madre
mamma mi ha detto cosa vuoi per natale
francesca io ho detto guarda c'è una
cosa che vorrei tantissimo però non
sosterrà troverai che è praticamente
questo gioco e come farlo nessuno
conosce che si chiama to be è abbastanza
famoso è abbastanza famoso però la
versione per la playstation è
introvabile è una cosa con imposto
lancia una petizione
siccome dal 1100 gioco con la demo si
sommi e non riesco a trovare il gioco
intero se qualcuno ce l'ha anche solo
per prestarmelo e capire come finisce
per che da vent'anni che lo voglio
finire grazie
facciamo qualcosa per questa ragazza
[Musica]
ciao a tutti sono francesca sono una
studentessa di 23 anni
sto studiando si mostri che in realtà
voi non sapete cosa fare della mia vita
cerco un anima gemella e voglio trovarle
assolutamente ragazzi over 30 mi
raccomando c'è il meno di 30 non li
voglio vedere di grande cultura e
abbiamo fatto almeno una campagna di
schiaffi scavi in africa perché
interessa proprio vorrei trovare
qualcuno che non si azzardo quanto
membri per trovare qualcuno mi fingo
alberto angela sto tornando ceca
ok